la parole est à Monsieur HUG Portelli
pour le groupe Union pour un mouvement
populaire merci monsieur le Président
madames messieurs les membres du
gouvernement mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des
Transports les usagers du Transilien
Île-de-France ont pris malheureusement
l'habitude depuis des années de subir
les dysfonctionnements dans les
transports or depuis le mois de janvier
et bien ce dysfonctionnement a pris une
ampleur
nouvelle notamment sur la principale
ligne de transport de toute la France le
RER A tous les jours des trains sont
supprimés tous les jours des rames
arrivent en retard une autre ligne la
ligne j la ligne j bien voit elle aussi
des trains régulièrement supprimés des
trains régulièrement arrivés en retard
sur la ligne H où pourtant on a changé
les trains récemment où le transcilien
étaé installé et bien là encore et pas
plus tard qu'hier tous les jours il y a
des suppressions de train sur la ligne B
sur la ligne C régulièrement il y a des
dysfonctionnements régulièrement dans
tous ces trains le nettoyage n'est pas
assuré correctement alors monsieur le
ministre je voudrais vous poser
simplement quelques questions
premièrement quand supprimeraton enfin
l'interconnexion SNCF RATP sur les
lignes A B et
D deuxèm
quand introduira-t-on enfin des rames à
deux étages sur la ligne A troisièmement
quand la SNCF daignera-t-elle répondre
aux questions des usagers quand il lui
demande pourquoi les trains sont
supprimer ou arrive en
retard qurièmement comment
expliquez-vous que les usagers de ces
lignes lorsqu'il se présente à un
entretien d'embauche se voit poser pour
première question comment pour compter
venir à votre travail quelle Lig de
transport utiliserez-vous et lorsqu'ils
répondent qu'ils utilisent lesg que je
viens de vous citer et bien la plupart
du temps leur candidature est écarté
alors monsieur le ministre nous sommes
nous sommes attachés au service public
des transports nous vous demandons de le
faire respecter et notamment par la
SNCF merci la parole est à Monsieur
frédrier ministre chargé des transp de
la mer et de la Pêche merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs monsieurs le
sénateurs et bien nous apprenons des
choses dans cette enceinte d'abord que
depuis le 6 mai la dégradation des
services est à ce point que vous en
faites porter la responsabilité sur ce
gouvernement que jusqu'à l'odeur dans
les RER et autres transports en commun
et remise en cause la propreté et que
nous avons par les transports en commun
une nouvelle explication chez Arnaud
Montebourg du niveau de chômage puisque
c'est une des conditions qui amène à ce
que les gens ne soient plus en situation
de pouvoir au-delà de la caricature à
laquelle vous vous livrez monsieur le
sénateur car votre
intervention votre intervention qui est
une intervention qui soulligne des
difficultés du quotidien elles sont pas
nouvelles elles sont même récurrentes et
qui est une situation à laquelle nous
nous attaquons depuis dès le premier
jour de la nomination d'abord je vous
ferai remarquer que
oui permettez-moi de vous indiquer un
certain nombre
d'information au-delà au-delà des cris
qui ne se justifient pas
particulièrement dans cette enceinte
j'ai la conviction elle est certainement
partagée que c'est en faisant en sorte
que les opérateurs que le Steve que la
région que l'État travaille ensemble que
nous pourra nous pourrons gommer les
dysfonctionnements qui sont trop
récurrents sur l'ensemble du réseau
parisien tout d'abord dans les
prochaines semaines suite au travail qui
a été piloté par Cécile Duflot le
Premier ministre va annoncer les
décision du calendrier de la réalisation
du plan de financement du Grand Paris
Express ce grand ce plan qui sera
annoncé sera accompagn également des
mesures d'amélioration du transport du
quotidien et je vous remercie de
souligner que l'un des enjeux qui a été
souligné par le Président de la
République et qui est mise en œuvre par
le gouvernement c'est-à-dire le
transport du quotidien est un enjeu que
quotidien précisément et un enjeu majeur
pour ce gouvernement nous faisons en
sorte que par la concrétisation
d'engagements qui sont anciens ces
projets ne soient plus du domaine de la
fable mais de la réalité et par ailleurs
nous souhaitons également avec la région
Île-de-France avec l'État accélérer des
opérations qui visent à moderniser le
réseau existant modernisation des
schémas directeurs du RER par exemple
travaille pour faire aboutir de nouveaux
projets indispensables à la désaturation
du réseau je pense ici au projet EOL qui
est indispensable les opérateurs l'état
la RATP la isncf sont également au côté
du STIF pour mener à bien des grands
projets de modernisation du matériel
roulant qui est indispensable à la
régularité et à la qualité à offerte aux
usagers rappelons soisit en passant
quand même que le Steve depuis la
décentralisation a lancé un vaste projet
de vastes projets le franilien des rames
à deux niveaux le r la rénovation des
matériel roulant sur les r B C et D nous
avons d'ors et déjà également demandé
l'amélioration de l'exploitation
notamment du centre de commandement
unique de la ligne B qui sera mise en
œuvre dès 2013 et par ailleurs j'ai
souhaité que cette réflexion soit mise
en œuvre sur la ligne a d'autre part le
président de la SNCF et de RFF d'ors et
déjà anticipe ce qui sera l'axe de la
réforme ferroviaire c'est-à-dire de
pouvoir coordonner améliorer le le
pilotage des travaux je vous remercie